you know we were all looking forward to  the Top Gun sequel especially when Jon  Hamm and Ed Harris got added to the  all-star cast but then they announced  the release date has been pushed back  need for speed right I guess more like  need for patience but we found out why  topping tonight's no Intel talk guns  like delayed  [Music]  it's going to be the Jets very fast jets  there's going to be an aircraft carrier  maybe two and the music music motorcycle  volleyball scene  maybe we'll see we're all gonna have to  wait an extra year to hear Tom say this  I'm maverick AG has learned that the  highly anticipated sequel to the number  one film from 1986 has been pushed back  from a summer 2019 released to the  summer of 2020 the reason production  needs more time to shoot complex aerial  sequences  we're told the sequel which began  filming May the 30th could have been  ready for a fall 2019 release but the  studio felt top guns had to be a summer  movie here we go  [Music]